was that clap for Ravi or is that for me
my back look at every every 30 seconds
another opportunity is my back God's not
as interesting as Stuart but that's okay
that's why we back really talented
people like Stuart well thank you so
much for giving us the opportunity to
speak today I was telling the folks when
I first arrived that whatever chance I
ever had of getting into Stanford I was
showcase that I had no no chance of game
the Stanford by the fact that I couldn't
even find the directions to get here so
that was not a good start for me in my
Stanford career but I made my way to
this beautiful building and in front of
all of you to be able to spend time with
was Stuart today and I thought maybe we
would start off by asking Stuart to
maybe just talk a little bit about your
background because I think when you
think about the products that Stewart
has put together with his team's over
the years I think many of them are
reflection of not just you know what
he's done in his professional life but
but it's sort of his journey as an
individual and as a person you know
through through life and it's an
interesting background would love for
you to share a little bit of that with
the group here sure so even though
there's all you know like the commune
and why should mention yes born in a log
cabin and didn't have running water or
electricity I think running water when I
was three and electricity when I was for
something like that but I'm gonna skip
way ahead from there I'll show you
starting college in 1992 so that was a
really fortuitous time I think among the
first things that happened when I got to
school wise i got an account on the
school's UNIX machine and discovered IRC
and use net and talk and email so a lot
of early internet technologies and there
was a a world wide web then but it
wasn't very popular I I hadn't heard of
it took me another year so before that
was something was on my radar but
immediately was blown away by the power
the danger to had to connect people I
was from a pretty small town in British
Columbia Victoria British Columbia and I
was at the University Victoria and my
friends who went away to different
school
I can communicate with them but also i
could find people who shared interest in
the same obscure philosophers and the
same obscure music and saw even back
then you know when there's maybe tens of
thousands of people online in total
including all of the academics there
were communities for model train
enthusiasts and there were communities
for breast cancer survivors and that
experience of I've seen technologies
power to connect people was the theme
that if it goes through everything that
I did since so I had because the web
came up while I was in college my summer
job every summer was making web pages
for people HTML was simple enough that I
could learn it back then and I sorry
philosophy I went to grad school my plan
was to be a philosophy professor and the
97 98 academic year I finished my
masters and they had the option to
continue and I had two good professors
both of whom said this is a terrible
life don't do it but I also had a good
friend of mine who finished his PhD or
the year before me and got his first job
and as the University of Louisville in
Kentucky and it was like 32 grand a year
with no job security had to renew every
year and he didn't want to live in
Kentucky and that was that was like a
good outcome and i still had many hoops
left to jump through to get there but
because it was 97 98 it was like the
very beginning of the dot-com era um
there's a lot of excitement and make us
that's a year after the Netscape my p.o
right around the Yahoo IPO Yeah right
around that time and friends who were
doing web stuff we're making twice as
much money as exciting and new so I
think I made it my choice there and and
began my career in internet stuff to
talk a little bit about what attracted
you I mean even if you look back whether
it be a grand finder which was sort of a
if it's possible maybe a worse
classmates com yep product if they want
to remember is that product then to the
game never ending and the flickr and
obviously to slack and that theme of
of whether you call it social networking
or or communication or community has
been you know consistent across all the
things that you've been passionate about
on the internet and talk a little bit
about why is that the case why have you
focused so much of your time and your
effort in that arena versus versus
others I think because this is something
that is probably clear now to more
people than ever because of the rise of
Facebook and we chat and whatsapp and
you know a thousand other things that
the fundamental application of computing
technology and human beings lives is
communication and that's you know that
wasn't true and say like the 1940s when
the fundamental application of computing
technology was calculating the
trajectory of surface-to-air missiles
and it wasn't true in the 50s when the
fundamental application was tabulating
the census or replacing double-entry
accounting and there was huge
productivity gains that we got through
that and up to maybe the 1980s but the
real potential and and this is like an
experience that most of you will have
every once in a while you turn on your
computer and there is no Wi-Fi here you
can't tether there is no connection and
a computer that's not connected to
probably not now Stanford no hold on
yeah we go on vacation yes I maybe and
your computer is like this inert thing
that doesn't really work unless it's
connected to the Internet there's so
many ways in which people can connect
and the game stuff and we could talk
about the origins and all that but we'll
talk about the game stuff yeah yeah okay
so but games was never about games for
me it was about creating a environment
for people to interact using play as the
kind of substrate so people like playing
bridge with other human beings for
example or playing golf or playing
Settlers of Catan or whatever and that's
just a thing that we do together just
like other forms of play that are less
structured you know that might be
wordplay or
witticisms or just great dinner
conversation or flirting or whatever
flickr the games grad finder or slack is
all about people talking to each other
and trying to figure out ways to get
make software do a better job of that
let's talk a little bit about your
gaming experiences haven't been the most
successful games no in the world
terrible games yeah but you know and I
think in both cases you know obviously
some some greatness has come out of
those experiences whether it be how many
of you know the the flickr story raise
your hand if you know the flickr story
see it's been a while yeah i don't think
people to talk to it talk a little bit
about what in in both cases whether it
be flickr or now with slack those those
products and those applications were
essentially birth out of failures to
create a great game a social and a
community-oriented game and maybe talk a
little bit about 22 similar outcomes in
terms of korean something that's
fantastic and now is the the belle of
the ball but but two different time
frames and two different experiences and
what about you specifically has made you
resilient through those experiences to
be able to take the journey all the way
through to create something really
unique and special okay so here's the
the flickr story short version in the
summer of two thousand two me and a few
other friends started a company to build
a web-based massively multiplayer game
and the general average age were called
she's in the sec this is when you were
still in elementary school but 2002 was
a terrible time to start any kind of
internet focused business it was
terrible time to start any kind of
business because first of all there was
a dot-com crash which still hadn't quite
shaken out but there was also the world
calm and Enron accounting scandals there
was 911 so the you know we think that
the markets have a little bit of turmoil
now in those days the S&P
down sixty-five percent from its high
Nasdaq was down eighty percent no one
was interested in investing anything
that had anything to do with the
internet but especially not consumer
face and stuff and within that
especially not something as frivolous as
a game so we had raised a little bit of
friends and family money we'd built a
prototype people like the prototype
there's a little community but it's
gonna take us another year and a half to
we had to produce something that we felt
like was going to be commercially and
commercially viable and no one would
invest like really and there were there
wasn't much investment in anything in
the general sense then so flickr was a
last-ditch attempt to take the
technology that we had already developed
and apply it to something else so we
were working on a web-based massively
multiplayer game and we had this game
client i connected to a server and at
the bottom of the screen there was
little slots for inventory you could go
pick up things in the world in fact one
of the items you could pick up in this
game world was slack because it was a
very absurd and it's a real kind of
Monty Python dr. Seuss asked world and
you would get bonus points for picking
up slack we replaced that with photos
and the the experience so the idea for
Flickr actually came over night I had
food poisoning I was feverish dream but
it all came to me once and that's
actually literally true but it was a
terrible product I mean it was
technically super cool and it made a
great demo at the time especially people
are writing this thing in a web browser
and you could chat and you could drop
photos and they pop up in someone else's
screens and you could annotate the
photos but you had to be connected at
the same time as then and you can only
see photos that they were showing you at
the time they were connected the odds
that someone you actually cared about
being connected to this service that was
you know that was a nascent service I
didn't have any users was about zero so
again great demo but terrible product so
that vision that came all at once and
the food poison fever dream wasn't a
very good one but it really quickly
iterated from there by the middle part
of 2004 it was growing like this there
wasn't I don't know that there was a
quite a reliable yet at that time in
in the investment community in internet
stuff but it was just starting to pick
up the first web two point O conference
was that fall of two thousand four and
by early two thousand five I had the
choice between the term sheet actually
from Excel and being acquired by yahoo
and we made the right decision yes so
after three and a half years of Yahoo
myself and three of the original flickr
team cal henderson sergei volkov and
eric costello decided we're going to try
this again so it's seven years later
technologies advanced computers away
fast you can't be wrong twice no like
wow what are the odds that you could be
wrong about the same thing twice yeah
and there's many more people online and
we were better at what we did there's
all this cool open source technology
that had moved the the ball down the
line a little bit or so we thought and
people were used to paying for stuff
online and there were other examples of
massively multiplayer games which at the
time were pretty successful and so we
decided we're gonna try it again and in
contrast in 2009 even though this was
right after the big financial crisis
they don't think they really had much of
an impact on vc investing in tech stuff
it was easy for us to raise money now we
were well known we raised i think a
million and a half bucks the seed round
and then five million dollar series a
and then a year later a
ten-million-dollar Series B and there
was all this initial traction and people
liked it but there was many reasons why
I didn't work the chief among them was
people you know ninety eight percent of
people who came in the front door left
right away they just they didn't
understand what it was it was too
strange this is at a time when farmville
was like on fire and that very very
simple idea of social gaming was was one
that was really problem and here's the
the part that I'm going to get asked
after this for all the aspiring
entrepreneurs what is the big lesson
well there were four of us who started
that company like I said two of us were
in Vancouver British Columbia one was in
San Francisco one was in New York
and so the way that we like the natural
mode for us to communicate was a product
called IRC which actually predates the
web by a couple years from 1989 and how
many of you actually know what IRC is
how many people have heard of IRC all
right so maybe a third eye or C stands
for Internet Relay Chat and it's a
messaging system where messages are
directed to what are called channels
rather than individuals or groups of
individuals kind of hit the peak of its
popularity in the mid to late 90s and
still used by the open source community
a lot of software developers but because
this form 89 has all these deficiencies
so if Andrew and I were on the same IRC
system and I wanted to change you a
message and he wasn't connected to the
time that I let the instant I wanted to
send him the message and I just couldn't
do it there's no concept of store and
forward it's not like say I message on
your phone where you can just send a
message to someone anytime you feel like
it so the first thing we did is built a
system to log these messages so we would
have archives and once we had archives
you wanted to be able to search them and
then over the course of three and a half
years working in the game we got to put
about 45 people and every time one of
our internal communication problems got
to the point where we just couldn't
stand it anymore we would spend the
minimum number of minutes addressing
that and then move on and slowly iterate
so we didn't know it at the time and it
wasn't obvious and this wasn't even
obvious like being told like a year ago
in this very non self conscious non
speculative way we were designing slack
but based on the actual needs that we
had as a team that was distributed needs
that we had as a team that was deep in
technological development that I don't
agree of coordination is working on the
game we had artists and animators the
sound designers level builders we had
people making content pipeline tools to
bring all that stuff together and just
like any other business most of your
daily effort is in communication and no
matter what your job is like you're so
your job might be doing stuff in Excel
or might be doing stuff in an IDE or
doing stuff in Salesforce or whatever
your role specific function is but most
of the time is someone telling you what
you're supposed to be doing you
attending a meeting discussing what
or writing email about what you are
doing and just that that need to
coordinate people is a really big part
of how we work so this is you know kind
of the good news and the bad news is
over after a couple years we have some
insight into why it was successful the
bad news is that it's that's a hard
thing to replicate to be able to
actually design something while not
actively thinking about it but it's
definitely the best way because I think
one of the biggest problems that
software designers product managers
entrepreneur's have is the temptation to
be really speculative with what some
hypothetical person would want as
opposed to something that you know you
need so yeah what was that about the
game I forget okay was awesome was a
little bit was a it was a little bit
about this idea of what you know
resiliency and people ask me a lot about
Stewart and you know what what makes him
tick what's why is he unique why has he
been able to do what he's done multiple
times at massive scale and you know
there's he's obviously you can like turn
away and not blush well I say this he's
very handsome of course which is very
helpful but he's very smart he has this
I always talk about this combination of
art and design plus engineering and sort
of technical competence and those two
things or are incredible traits you know
to have individually but when you
combine them there the creative forces
that come with that I think make make
Stuart really unique because he's
phenomenal up both sides of that
equation but also I think and most
importantly as an entrepreneur he's
resilient and you know he's been knocked
down multiple times and he's picked
himself back up and and been able to
rally you know a group of individuals
and people and investors and in markets
around his new ideas and and that's
something that you know you that's hard
to train it's hard to imagine how you
can get better at something like that
some of that's just an eighth to the
human and I think that is you know one
of the things that we look
for as investors in great entrepreneurs
we look for that idea of resiliency
because you know a lot of the things
that you hear about in the market these
overnight successes they're not their
journeys and they have ups and downs I
mean Stewart started tiny speck which
birthed glitch which was the game that
then led to slack in 2009 that was six
years ago slack is not an overnight
success and it's not because his team
stuck with it and Stewart stuck with it
and so going back to the to the flicker
days I think another really important
component of Flickr which will lead into
slack is I don't think people and given
you know sort of the fact that a lot of
folks here didn't know the background of
flicker I don't think people fully
understand and recognize how innovative
flickr was from a technical perspective
and this idea of what we take for
granted now in terms of a lot of the
background infrastructure that's
available to developers and software
designers today a lot of the choices
allow the architecture of web to dada
was really in some ways showcase by
flickr so maybe talk a little bit about
some of the decisions that you made
early on and building flickr from an
open API you know perspective from
thinking about it as a community tool I
mean how many of us in this room have
tagged a photo recently on facebook on
wherever we're Instagram right or
Twitter and Flickr really was birthed
Agee I mean delicious which was Joshua
ich nur obviously had tagging as well
but but flickr is really where that idea
of being able to have a community an
individual's tag an image came from so
talk a little bit about some of the
innovations there and have some of those
things have fueled the web and what you
think how it applies to slack moving
forward all right so I mean one of the
things was that we didn't have a whole
lot to lose at the point we decided to
work on slacks we'd we'd run out of
money the only person who got paid was
the one person on the team who had kids
liquor not black it's your absolutely
right you didn't run out of money in on
slack we did not almost
so beaded position where you don't have
anything to lose makes some decisions a
lot easier one of those was having open
API so people could do whatever they
want but they're also that was and and
this might come to pass again at some
point an area of really rapid innovation
not just by us but by a whole bunch of
people because the commercial focus was
off of the internet because that wasn't
you know like people graduating from
great schools were going to investment
banks and management consultancies
instead of coming here and starting
companies and that gave a little bit of
breathing space I think for
technologists engineers then like this
is like a little bit of a creative
Renaissance I think it's also just
because we had hit a point where enough
people knew what they were doing at the
time that we started working on flickr
we had no idea what we're doing but most
people did there was a handful of people
in the world at ebay at yahoo at Google
who had built things at internet scale
and maybe a few thousand engineers who
were good at that in fact Cal Henderson
like co-founders CTO after like a couple
years after flickr was acquired
literally wrote the book building
scalable web sites because no there
wasn't a book that said that there
wasn't a book that laid out how well you
know what the architecture would be like
and that was very influential the time
but I think it's also a really nice call
and response with the people using the
product so there was a very much a
community focus at the time that flickr
started the only web sites where you
could upload photos were ones that were
designed to get you to print and the
that was private closed off it wasn't a
place where you could show it share and
showcase and bob baxley who's now the
head of design at interests was it yahoo
at the time Apple Apple in between had a
great line on that which was flickr was
a great place to be a phono so if you
were going to be a photo then you had a
happier life inside of that kind of
ecosystem we actually want to go back to
the resiliency thing because here's
here's the part that you don't imagine
when you start a company where you
probably don't so
one of the things you got to do is tell
a story that people can believe in
whether that's the investors whether
that's co-founders whether that's
employees you're trying to bring on
board that's customers that's potential
users that's like what the brand is well
as landlords everyone yeah you gotta
tell a friend maybe your significant
other or your parents or whoever and you
really have to hope that that comes true
and then often the way that you said it
the first time doesn't happen and so you
altered the story and then that also
doesn't happen and then you alter the
story again and that still doesn't
happen and at some point you think am i
stupid am I crazy am i lying about this
is there something here or am I just
gonna have to keep on changing the story
as reality punches me in the face over
and over again so we had the experience
I think it with this company that ended
up being a huge success of it failing
and the the feeling was not like well
chin up old fellow we're going to try
again it'll all be okay in the end it
was like just personally speaking from
the inside horrible sorry I'm a
chef from the last really um you're
Canadian yeah like so actually I mean I
still remember this very very well we
had tried all these things were working
the new user experience we're looking at
monetization were building this model
we're saying like you know what you do
this we do that we had five million
bucks left in the bank there's always
one thing that was coming up that was
going to be the thing that would make
this work and you know sometimes those
things where we we pegged all our hopes
on would actually move the needle a
little bit but not quite enough and
that's the hardest position to be in not
not quite failing not quite succeeding
we actually had very very high average
revenue per user we had you know deep
commitment Annika's community that was
really into it but just not enough and
november 11 I was as I do and I still do
I had trouble falling asleep that's just
like my mind was racing thinking about
and I just knew this is not going to
work because I don't believe it's going
to work anymore and if I stop believing
there's like no foundation for anyone
else to believe and so I wrote you guys
an edge was on the board of directors I
wrote them an email saying that I talked
to the founders two days later I'm
standing in front of the company and
telling them and it shut down so that
might sound bad but here's how it's
really bad it gets worse oh yeah well
there was this moment I'm we call a
special all hands meeting we didn't
normally have them on Wednesdays and we
had two offices we had this video linkup
between the two and everyone's wondering
what's up I don't thing anyone had any
idea that this was coming and I get up I
said okay they don't have a deck or if
like that I just have to tell everyone
that you don't have a job anymore and
right when I start talking I just
happened to be looking around the room I
lock eyes with this one engineer who
three months earlier I had convinced to
move to a new city away from his in-laws
who are helping take care of his 18
month old and buy a house and like it
was a it took me so long to convince
this guy to make the move and I told him
how great it was going to be and like it
was a really fun and project you get to
work with lice amazing people and look
at these business metrics they're just
about to go up and and I then should go
to psychoanalysis or something like that
I have a very strong desire to avoid
disappointing people as many of you also
have and this was like this is more than
a disappointment this was like I
up his life like he had made the wrong
choice moving to a new city not having
the support of his family having the
small child and not having a job so
before I even actually said anything I'm
crying and I'm like then people are like
this is a weird
everyone's a little bit uncomfortable so
that took several like weeks of just
real emotional turmoil in pain and it's
so that's horrible to have to tell
people that they lost their job in a
minute it's also very terrible from
their perspective of course as well it's
humiliating you know like so there is so
much riding on this it was disappointing
our investors it was disappointing like
all of our friends who who's like time
we had sacrificed to say that we're not
going to do this thing I'm not gonna go
visit my parents I'm not going to hang
out with my girlfriend and I'm going to
be working and working and working and
all of that was for nothing so in this
case the story has a much happier ending
for a couple reasons that we can get
into but that's a that's the part that
you don't think about and and I think
that's good just like you know if you're
jumping from one rock to another on a
beach sidewalk you don't think about the
horrible ways you could slip and fall
but it is not for everyone like I there
are and this there's been a couple cases
in the last year I think of founders
even if companies that have done pretty
well just ended up committing suicide
because the pressure is so great I guess
the last thing I'll say is that was a
horrible period is very very stressful
and since then many things have worked
out incredibly well and I'm here and we
raised hundreds of millions of dollars
and the business is growing a three
percent a week still and it's incredible
and we have no problem recruiting from
any company that we want and the
pressure is about the same it's about
with the same emotional intensity
because now the expectations are that
much higher there's that much more
riding on it it's like that much more
visible on the cover of magazines and
like I also know just from past
experience that there is a cycle and we
are in this and it's very hard to convey
this to employees I think that we're in
this moment where it's not going to get
any better like this is we have six
months like this maybe we have 18 months
probably a year
where again we have no real competition
the business growing like crazy it's
easy for us to recruit and we also have
a special advantage I think that all of
the media use of slack so just like
Twitter in 2010 where approximately zero
percent of the world used Twitter but a
hundred percent of journalists did and
so they thought it was very important
approximately zero percent of the world
uses lack one hundred percent of
journalists do so they think it's very
important but it's not going to get
better than this right and the the
mental preparation that you have to do
to prepare yourself for the first leg
what's left doing and you see you can
see that in all kinds of companies that
there's that this enthusiasm there's
this amazing support people think you're
a genius and then it's like it you don't
you stop growing quite as quickly and
then a little bit skeptical and then
there's medium posts about the death of
this company that has hundreds of
millions of dollars of you and you know
that put is actually a great example
because you talk to any VC and a lot of
people in the industry and the same
Twitter piece of crap company they're
dead and it's you know a 15 20 billion
dollar company that didn't exist nine
years ago so like that's that's that's
the that's the death case so even you
know they're the degree of cynicism hate
criticism that you that you get is going
to be high so still writing the nice way
but prepared for the bad one yeah but
during that time too i think you know
Stuart and the team I think this is
indicative of the the culture and we'll
get into slacks culture because I do you
think that's really unique and puts them
in a a very enviable position as relates
to building the company and recruiting
great people they did something
extraordinary things they I remember
Stewart calling me and saying that we're
going to shut it down and have the
conversation today but we're going to
spend the next month doing everything we
can to help all the employees get jobs
and we're going to give him really
generous severance and are you okay with
that and of course we were and I think
maybe a week later they had law
a website called hire a genius yep was
that it right hire a genius which was a
website of all the folks that have been
laid off from slack and their resumes
and I think Stewart probably did I don't
know how many references and reference
letters reference calls and resume
college and I mean I imagine most
companies you know when whatever company
lays off 500 people or a thousand people
building a website and marketing the
people as really talented folks to the
rest of the you know the the employee
employment base in a general area I
think it just speaks to the type of
person Stewart is the type of leader he
is so let's talk a little bit about as
we move past some of these challenges
and we move into this zone of slack and
the unprecedented success and speed in
which you all are operating talk a
little bit about why what why is this
happening what are the what
preconditions are in place what what
what is driving all of this momentum and
this in this product and this category
in this business so there's definitely
some external conditions which are
really important and if we started slack
three years earlier I don't think it
would have taken off in any anything
like the way it did part of that is
another six to eight hundred million
people coming online via Facebook and
they're similar number of people coming
on line outside of Facebook but with the
with the idea of messaging and messaging
for me I mean like I said 1992 I got my
first UNIX account and messaging was all
the internet was and in the late 90s I
had icq and that's what messaging was
and in 2005 we talked about the
strategic importance of yahoo messenger
versus msn messenger bush said I don't
even know if either that exist anymore
um and I had a blackberry 13 years ago
or whenever that was so that it's always
seemed like an obvious simple part of
the internet and technology and
computers and that's not true for most
people so my mum's the first message she
sent me so she's gonna be many emails
and other modes of communication but the
first like text message she sent me was
two years ago and the proliferation of
iPhones and Android devices and the rise
of SMS as a as a mode of communication
is something that's going to be like it
probably feels super weird to you if
you're 20 years old and this was
something that you did since you were a
little kid but it's a new thing in the
world and it's also a new thing for most
human beings so people are accepting of
the idea of a messaging app being the
way that they interact with people so
they're ready for a messaging app for
work I think it's also a bunch of
critical technologies that were ready at
the right time the proliferation of
networks it's only been a couple years
since we've had great internet pretty
much wherever you go in your pocket like
it used to be 10 years ago when I first
got to know Andrew the very coolest
phone that anyone in the world could get
and it was on backorder it was really
hard to get ahold of was the Motorola
RAZR and I don't even know if that you
guys know what that is but like the
little flip phone it was very thin and
you could do things with it including
make phone calls and place like I
thought you were so cool because you had
one of them and that was it like so that
wasn't the idea that you would use the
internet on a mobile device was totally
not a question so I think those things
make a difference I think there's a lot
of external factors some inside I know
you don't like this answer very much but
a part of it as lock part of his like
having the right people use at the right
time part of it i think was the goodwill
that so when we shut down glitch we had
five million dollars left we could have
kept going we could have like till we
completely ran out of money but because
we had money left in the bank we could
say to our customers you have the option
of getting taking your money back or
letting us donated a charity or letting
us keep it we got to spend enough time
with our employees that every single
person got another job and i think those
things you know those kinds of Acts make
a difference and people are much more
likely to support you I also think that
we had that that interesting period of
time held almost three three-and-a-half
years where we tested this system you
know on ourselves again totally
unselfconscious
not not looking for the results but just
every time something didn't work we made
it work in the minimum amount of time
and then took the next step so those are
hard conditions to replicate and it's
also maybe not something that needs to
be replicated because I camera who told
me this once but there was this it was a
pretty well-known bias at Google towards
hiring people from a pretty small subset
of all the world's universities because
a lot of the people who worked at Google
in the very early days were from here or
from MIT or from Harvard and so they
thought hey we're super successful and
we're hiring all these people from these
great schools hiring people from great
schools will make us successful and it
could have been that everyone at Google
had red hair and then they would think
like all we got to do is find more
people in red hair and that's going to
we're definitely gonna be successful or
everyone who works here is you know
under 5 foot 8 so we just got to hire a
bunch of short people and then no
problem we would fit in here yeah the
the confluence of factors that have to
come into play in order for something to
be successful are tremendous so it's
like the quality of the design the
technical infrastructure doesn't fall
down your ability again to tell the
story in a way that people are going to
understand is is incredibly important
the alignment that you have to get among
a group of people and that's something
that's still I think at 42 years old
still learning as an integer is the
degree to which alignment matters more
than the exact direction in which you're
aligned so I don't know could I answer
way yes well we good you did why don't
we yeah kinda um I think the lock part
might be the most important piece talk a
little bit about you know we'll talk
about all we talk about culture at the
company and then maybe we can talk a
little bit about your vision for slack
because I think people have not yet
fully understood where what the
potential of slack is and how you think
about it from a platform for versus
maybe a pure application standpoint but
before we do that let's talk a little
bit about the culture of slack we're
obviously in Silicon Valley there's a
large emphasis
you know diversity and an empathy and
transparency and authenticity and all of
those things which are all buzz words
that are easy to say but but hard to
practice so talk a little bit about your
your thoughts on that I would be happy
to so actually here's another factor
that I think helped in the success was
that by the time we started to work on
slack that was again too early 2013 all
of the four co-founders had worked
together for at least 10 years and at
this point one of the co-founders I have
now worked with for 18 years so there's
a very very high degree of trust and
understanding of people's capabilities
and knowing how to work with these
people that that was the the core of the
team and in addition we had been through
this traumatic experience so there's
eight people who made the transition
from glitch to working and slack and
going through trauma what the group of
people is the best bonding experience
you could have and we had worked with
them for several years so like that that
makes a really big difference it also
instructed the kind of culture that we
wanted to have we made some really great
early hires um and in a lot of those
decisions of the early days that you
could you don't have enough information
to make the decision properly it could
be this and it could be this and so
after some consideration and by the way
John do are once gave me some I think is
really good advice if a decision is
really really hard to make then it the
probably doesn't matter because if it's
that close it doesn't matter and and
sometimes you write sometimes you're
wrong we were right many times we've got
a couple of great hires our chief of
staff or engineering is a guided Nolan
Caudill who wrote this great piece that
when we were about 30 employees about
building the kind of workplace that we
would want to have and identifying at
that time three traits that we would
look for in people and one of them was
empathy and that was something that was
at the core of the company in the
beginning just from my perspective it's
very difficult to design something well
if you don't have any empathy for the
people who are using it in fact I bet
these probably the most important skill
that a designer can have because you
can't step back from your own emotions
and your own ego about how the things
should
your idea versus somebody else on the
team's idea and really put yourself in
the shoes of human being who's going to
be using this software then it's I don't
know your your chances of success are
coin flips another one was curiosity and
another one was diligence and those have
morphed over the years and we actually
on our day two of onboarding for new
employees is the CEO welcome and I start
by telling them we had a management
off-site to discuss corporate values and
then wait for them wait for the grown
and what came out of that was empathy as
expressed by courtesy expressed through
courtesy and you can be courteous
without being empathic a lot of
psychopaths are super skilled and being
great with people and not having any
empathy craftsmanship tempered by
playfulness and playfulness in the sense
doesn't just mean silliness or whimsy oh
I think we got away with just enough of
that in the bridge so to be accessible
to people and authentic but playfulness
in that sense means willingness to
improvise and be creative and to try to
anticipate where other people are doing
if any of you have ever played team
sports or playing improvisational music
you'll know that attempts that you make
to both act in a way that's going to be
helpful to your teammates or your fellow
musicians while simultaneously
anticipating what they're going to do
and paying attention to what they're
doing now and that's a kind of
playfulness that we mean and then the
last one was and this this comes
straight from the philosophy degree is
thriving which is really because when we
said flourishing everyone thought we
meant like this Aristotle's eudaimonia
ethics discussed this kind of happiness
that one gets from fulfilling their
purpose irrespective of what the purpose
is so doing the thing that you're meant
to do in the sense that like a knife is
meant to cut dings and so a good knife
is a sharp knife at he does get into a
little bit when he Aristotle thinks that
people should do but that's irrelevant
there is a feeling that you get what
you're really engaged in something you
know sometimes people talk about the
flow state and when you're doing the
thing that you're you're meant to be
doing that's incredibly valuable so the
last set of values thriving both in
ourselves and in others so the last one
is solidarity and that's very strange
for for like as a list of values for a
high tech company because most lists of
values are like excellence integrity I
don't know what else would be on that
list but they're completely generic and
people forget them the day after they
have their new employee welcome and
those have been kind of guiding
principles and also good checks against
business decisions that were making like
does this actually make sense bill
mastitis our CMO who came over from
zendesk is I think unusual for a CMO in
that his chief focus is are we making
customers happy because if we're making
customers happy then they're going to
stay with the service and that's you
know a critical factor in our business
success and they're going to recommend
us and one hundred percent of our growth
so far has been on the basis of people
recommending or ninety seven percent of
our growth has been on the basis of
people recommending us and that's
unusual and it's very much in alignment
with our values and one of the things we
do to check whether our decision is good
or not is to see like the extent to
which it's in accordance with those
values and what was the other thing
besides values that you ask diversity I
was going to do it in one minute oh god
yeah don't even see there's a time yeah
I saw it I've been watching it okay that
was a little you took that I had an
extra minute there but you took about my
name ok but just speak really quickly
about you launched a diversity report
one of the youngest companies Denver do
a diversity study and publish it I think
this is important maybe just in 30
seconds talk about why you did it um one
of the reasons we did it was to hold
ourselves accountable they had a number
of conversations with a whole bunch of
people who had a lot of respect for
including a woman named Joelle Emerson
who runs a consultancy called paradigm
who've been working with on unconscious
bias training a bunch of other things
also Eileen Lee
former client partner it now at cowboy
ventures who actually coined the word
unicorn data was a diversity event with
her that actually the White House
sponsored Megan Smith and we one of
those we talked about was like a pledge
from CEOs that this would actually be
something that was awarding and I you
know part of it is internal you can't
manage what you don't measure so you
know just knowing what the numbers were
and to hold our feet to the fire I guess
you have to put it out there and then be
accountable to the press because the
press is shifted to the point where like
you know shifted from it would be nice
if there's more diversity in Silicon
Valley to in the minds of I think a lot
of journalists at least this is
something that we are going to grill
people on forever so like having having
that kind of you know almost vociferous
pneus hold you to account i think is
really valuable it's great questions you
you choose collections yeah um sure
she'll write shirk in the fifth row that
got six okay justification for years oh
well so it's like we were using the red
whatever working on glitch it was IRC
plus a whole bunch of stuff that we had
done oh I'm sorry yes okay so what I
mean not if I have the question right
what kinds of communication tools were
you using but while you were even before
you had built slack and the previous
companies here's the interesting thing
we ask our customers what did you use
before slack and eighty percent of them
say nothing because they don't think
about internal communication as a
product category in the way that if you
were going to start a sales force today
you would choose a CRM at the moment
that you got started playing that and if
you were going to start an engineering
team you would choose a system for
source control you just wouldn't start
writing code
you had chosen some system for managing
that code but you say the I'm going to
start a new team and they start a new
company i'm going to start a new project
you don't make a decision about internal
communication so it was haphazard and
scattered and it was like Kabul people
are on hangouts acabo people are in
skype chat we see customers who have
used private facebook groups there's
Yammer and chatter and convo and social
facts and all that stuff there's
obviously things that are very much like
slack there's hipchat and photo a
condition IRC itself but most of all
there's email and the thing that I would
say that we found and this is probably
in retrospect is if you can't contain
the whole spectrum of communication from
this is an important memo that everyone
at the company must read too I'm going
to be 10 minutes late for this meeting
so why don't you just get started
without me if you can't like get that
whole range then it's going to be
another thing that you have to check so
you still have to do both of these I
think that was the problem that we tried
Yammer in 2010 and there's a tweet for
me in 2010 or maybe 2011 saying WOW
Yammer is amazing and we had this
initial burst of enthusiasm that lasted
about six weeks before he realized now
we had another thing that we had to
check so we didn't like those customers
who say they use nothing we used nothing
next question oh boy there's a bunch
questions white trade the second row
then ventured in the first grow itch
like to raise my flag app I me right out
of meh successful venture well so I
guess this is I guess we kind of skipped
over this um yeah yes what was the pitch
to raise money for slack after a less
successful venture all right yeah so
this one's kind of interesting so we had
we had raised 17 f nine dollars to work
on glitch and we had five million left
and they very prudently didn't want
their money back and so we still had
five million dollars to work on slack
and there was only eight of us and kind
of buckled down now we started working
and we did this preview release which is
kind of like a private beta and
once we felt like it was good enough we
did the full official launch people
could just sign up when we started
charging money and by that point it was
clear that this was going to be much
much more successful than we had
anticipated like the once teams start
using slap they essentially don't stop
people were happy to pay money for so by
the time that we had to go back to raise
more money because we had spent a
million and a half out of that five
million it was a quarter billion dollar
valuation and rising fast and the pitch
was look at these numbers essentially
there wasn't you know if there's enough
growth you don't really need any other
kind of story okay sorry Larry said red
shirt first robot can we do one more
after that one yeah really for 526 all
right okay so you mentioned that was
like this printer on period and can
usually make two or three the factors
that that works key to that turnaround
Crean that helps you create slack that
inflection point so talking about the
transition from which just left two or
three factors that helped us through
that so I think one of them would be the
depth of the relationship of the team so
that would have been and I think that I
don't know what the studies say but I
bet the studies say that most startups
fall apart not because they couldn't
raise money because investors were jerks
to them or something like that or even
because the product failed but because
the founders eventually had a falling
out and even in very successful cup base
that's you know that's often the case so
yeah one of the things would be the the
the depth of that relationship I guess
the second thing very quickly is that we
had come to a product design that was
just really good and we actually had
that before we started and it's
incredible as I just like a month ago
dugout this pitch deck now before we had
committed to the idea of doing slack we
had this pitch back it said codename
slack and I went down to present to the
accel partners and I presented in
Driessen Horowitz and everyone said yeah
but I guess you could try that you know
we'd rather you try something then give
us your my
back so go ahead but we did exactly this
is three years ago we did like we're
still executed against that same deck in
exactly the same way that's incredibly
rare because usually it's like
improvisational so Roddy Robbie take it
away Thanks thank you very much
you